foreign
yes Carrie this will be recorded we'll
be sending you a link to the recording
afterwards
yes Carrie this will be recorded we'll
be sending you a link to the recording
afterwards
foreign
two minutes away
Excuse me while I sip a cup of coffee
foreign
and as you can see we'll be getting
started in about one minute
okay we're coming up on the time
all right we'll get started
foreign
[Music]
our LinkedIn live streaming audience so
bear with me for a moment
here we go
foreign
live streaming audience our YouTube live
streaming audience and of course
everyone here on Zoom with us today
my name is Stuart Creek
and I'm with simply learn we are the
delivery partner for Caltech Center for
technology and management education
for this program on artificial
intelligence and machine learning boot
camp
and in partnership with IBM so I'll be
telling you about that today but you'll
be hearing from Mike Ash who is the
program director for this program with
Caltech
and we'll be asking a couple questions
about you along the way keep track of
those when we ask poll questions if you
are on a streaming service you can
answer by putting in a letter response
ABC or D
AB chat box or comment box on your
streaming service otherwise you'll have
a poll widget that comes up in Zoom
uh if you have questions for us to take
at the end of the session please put
those in the Q a on Zoom or in your
commenter chat and the streaming
services so we'll talk about uh careers
in the field
we'll talk about how this boot camp
prepares you for a career in the field I
will cover some learner outcomes
and I'll share with you enrollment steps
and a special bonus offer for those of
you who are here today on this webinar
um and as I said we'll take your q a
toward the end of the session so this
point I'd like to get started
um and I'm going to introduce uh or let
Mike Ash to introduce himself with some
comments he made at an earlier
session of this uh
preview so
here we are
I spent 25 years in in Consulting under
IBM and Deloitte
uh a press Waterhouse working with
companies uh leveraging Advanced
Technologies
um in IBM several projects around
cognitive Computing how do we exploit
new digital Technologies and and that's
what I do it I work with clients to make
their new strategic opportunities and in
digital initiatives uh whether that's
for
internal efficiency gains or they're
creating new platforms that they're
going to either sell or compete with
uh within Caltech we covered several
Industries because of our science and
engineering background
Aerospace energy
Electronics high-tech and what we try to
do in the programs that we have are
bring courses that could either build up
skills or help you develop leadership
skills and professional skills
and our audiences are typically people
who are technical in in the roles that
they play uh so we have this uh this
program and we're pretty excited about
it
and one of the reasons we think that
it's important is as we see how
companies are really trying to extend
the performance that they have uh
whether investing in new technologies
they're they're coming up against some
some obstacles and some barriers and the
only way is to get past those especially
dealing with all the data that comes in
from digital platforms is
being able to use advanced math and
machine learning to be able to
um not just manage that data but
interpret what is it telling you what is
it telling about the services that you
offer uh what is it telling you about
the customers who are using or the users
on a platform and because that is
growing and becoming more complex we
need Advanced tools just to deal with
this stuff right
um and so some of these machine learning
tools are in the background you don't
really notice them like recommendations
on Netflix
or on Spotify but they're also in places
where we as a research institution love
to do Advanced things and I'll talk
about those in just a second
uh
in a program like what we'll talk about
today which is a really a comprehensive
uh boot camp
it this is an intermediate program so
really for people who already have some
coding and development skills
but we really want to you're you're
looking to grow into a role where you
can use new skills and those might be as
a software architect or a developer
you're developing tools using machine
learning uh you're creating new
algorithms you're really improving the
uh
products through uh software they need
to
learns more about the problems that it
has to solve or uh about the the
environment around it
so
with the rigor that this program has
we're really trying to help people grow
into
these kinds of roles that that you see
and all of those are in high demand not
just within science and engineering but
within media and Communications and
medicine and consumer products and I
think you guys already know this and
that's why you're here
but
whatever trying to build new
competencies around Ai and machine
learning and advanced development
you need to have a
lot of different skills this is not just
a field that has one particular skill
um and some of these what you're going
to be exposed to are
skills that are methods and skills that
are around certain software and and the
libraries
um
the statistics as as a you know it's
just it's our
um
we're going to give you a background in
more of that and understanding
probability a little bit of linear
algebra
python we're going to be doing a lot of
coding in
um over on the far side if you see numpy
numpy is the one of the science and math
libraries for python
um and that's used extensively in in
work that we do in Caltech
um and and not just our group of course
the the larger Institute if you go to
the numpy website there are two case
studies that you'll see on their home
page uh one is how they use the tools
within that particular package to do the
Imaging of the Black Hole uh
m87 by Dr Katie Bowman's group Dr Bowman
lives in my building right here uh here
on campus uh her team uh worldwide
worked on the Imaging of m87 I think in
um other case study you'll see there is
for ligo which is a gravitational wave
Observatory that was also invented
um
initially theorized and invented here at
Caltech uh by Kip Thorne who got a a
Nobel Prize
um so these are the kinds of tools and
skills that you can use in any kind of
commercial business but also if you're
in science and engineering that really
want to do breakthrough things
uh
then we're going to help you get there
all right at this point I would like to
ask
a question of our audience
so
as Mike said you're all here because
you're interested in this field of
potentially becoming a AI ml
practitioner or extending your career
capabilities in that area so let me ask
what it has
stopped you to date from
getting involved in a program of this
type
so is it because you can't find a
program that covers all the different uh
skills and tools that that Mike talked
about is it because you don't have
confidence that you get practical
experience that you'd use to demonstrate
your new skills
is it because of the way most of the
programs are structured in a learning
environment or is it because of finding
time in your work schedule so uh if
you're on a streaming service you can
use a b c and d for these answers but uh
otherwise I'm going to keep this poll
open for about another 10 seconds for
our Zoom audience so please get your
answers in
I'm going to close the poll now in five
four
three
two
one
here you go
we're sharing the result
the biggest
concerned people have is uh being
confident that they'd be able to show
off their new skills with practical
experience
and then people are also worried about
finding a comprehensive curriculum or
finding time in their work schedule
so let's talk a little bit about those
things
and
I'm going to let Mike talk about the
artificial Intel intelligence machine
learning boot camp a little bit but just
wanted to give you a
quick few points it does have the
comprehensive curriculum which we'll
describe later for you it is an fully
online program that's available to you
on a platform that's open 24x7 so you
can fit it into your schedule at any
time that you've got time to work on it
and you do all of the
virtual classes live with your
instructors you do all the labs your
projects prep work is all in the same
environment so it's very easy
inconvenient you'll see a little bit
about that later
it's about 10 to 15 hours of time
dedication per week
and as you can see the the cost of the
program is uh
one dollar less than ten thousand
dollars so nine nine nine nine
and I'll be sharing with you a bonus
offer so let me ask Mike to
cover some of the points about the
program for you
um but
what we do in this program is use that
flipped classroom model that we're going
to give you uh
access to learning in cases and readings
to get familiar with something and then
come into a practice lab
weekly for eight hours on a part-time
basis
and
work through code work through different
examples work on project-based learning
and
like I mentioned earlier it's a methods
it's some of the math it's using these
tools
and then as you get that Foundation set
add on some more advanced tools this is
a comprehensive program that's why it's
six months it does require about 10 to
15 hours
every week uh we'll say that's mostly on
the weekends so there's a commitment for
live time with the class so this is not
a fully on demand 100 pre-recorded
there's a mix of pedagogies here there
are things that you'll review ahead of
time and then there's live sessions and
you have access to instructors and Tas
and help
throughout that process
and the these integrated Labs we're
going to have a an online
um like basically workbench learning
management system where you'll be able
to access code
um turn in uh homework some of the
exercises that you have see the videos
access other tools all that is in an
integrated environment
um and and that's one of the reasons we
really love simulator is because they
have that
uh and they've put that together
um so the entire class which will
probably have usually have between like
35 or 45 people in a in a cohort in a
class uh
and you'll be able to work through
projects uh
during that you'll have access to the
platform at all times
and it's set up in this way to
also meet the demands of people who are
fully employed who are either looking to
create new skills
that work invest some time to upskill
what they're doing you may have a little
bit of background in in machine learning
and Quant type tasks
you might already be an Excel jockey
this is going to take you to the next
level but we do it to try to help you
fit the demands that you have in your
life already
at the end you'll get a certificate from
Caltech like I said this is about six
months there's a culminating kind of
project at the end of Capstone which
we'll talk about in a minute
when you've successfully completed
everything
there's not a necessarily a test at the
end but there are certification steps
along the way
uh you also
be able to access some elective courses
um we've teamed with IBM to offer
kind of a deep dive into python for data
science
in this you'll be able to
join in some master class sessions which
are monthly with either a Caltech
instructor also a an IBM instructor
and do ask me anything sessions you have
any kind of question bring those up
understand how they are applying machine
learning in different cases and
scenarios
in the end you'll also get what are
called CEUs these are continuing
education credits this is important for
employers who may be reimbursing you for
tuition they might be funding this
program for you
this is a very common in the U.S I think
most people on this call this particular
boot camp is for a US audience
the CEUs that you're going to get
you you tell your employer about that
you show them the dates of the program
and that's how they'll typically uh fund
the tuition for you 22 CEUs converts to
220 Active Learning hours that's why
it's a six-month program 10 to 15 hours
every week
the 22 or 220 hours that's just Active
Learning that's the amount of content
that you have and in the lessons you're
doing stuff on your own that's even
extra time so as you think about putting
this program into your in your live uh
you need to plan around it
um the live sessions are meant for you
to be there
you need to engage in order to get the
most out of this so this is an
investment and you're going to be
greatly rewarded so with a certificates
you get the continuing education credits
you can join our private LinkedIn group
for all the Caltech ctme grads and
certificate holders
and then we'll also have a a
complication event online where you can
be a part of that experience or that and
maybe recognized and for certain Awards
all right
um
you probably know who Caltech is just in
case you don't uh this is the California
Institute of Technology we've been
around since 1891. and it we're a
science and engineering uh private
Institution
with engineering and applied sciences
which is my division that's where we are
that includes everything from computer
math Sciences electrical engineering
civil engineering structural
aerospace engineering and so on and
medical engineering we also have physics
math and astronomy
you may be familiar with the jet
propulsion lab or JPL we run that for
NASA
and there's
bio and bioengineering chemical and
chemical engineering and and Humanities
and guess what
machine learning is used in every single
one of those fields every single one of
those disciplines
in academics and in profession so what
Caltech does is excel at
taking computer and math sciences and
computational thinking
match it up with a field and really
Drive kinds of brand new results
and we've chosen to create these kinds
of boot camps to help
intermediate learners
build out new ways to help Advance their
careers and and do it in a way that's
kind of very fun and instructive
okay and
so you heard about uh our connection
with Caltech here and and the the
Caltech ctme program
uh We've also brought into it one of the
reasons that Caltech uh simply learned
as our delivery partner is our
connection with IBM which gives uh an
advantage in these programs for uh
providing information
capability so we're very pleased with
that aspect of it
uh
uh eligibility and prerequisites
prior experiencing or knowledge of
mathematics and programming you need to
come into this
with not necessarily uh
extensive background or work experience
in in those fields but you do need to
have a basic understanding
um
educational requirement is very simple
you have to have a high school a diploma
or equivalent uh you must be at least 18
years of age
um so this is a program that's suitable
for people who are very experienced but
also people who are just
starting out
um we prefer that you have two or more
experience years of experience in the
workplace
not mandatory
um
so
if you have that experience you'll have
a better understanding of how
Ai and ml work within the
organizational environment and you'll be
able to understand better how to apply
it but again it's not a mandatory
requirement so this plan would like to
ask
the audience how much experience do you
have
we'll ask this question
pretty straightforward so I won't leave
it open very long
just another uh
about 15 seconds from now
are you currently uh working on your
undergraduate degree or or in school for
a graduate degree are you in the
workforce
and I'll close the poll in five four
three two
one
sharing the results
so we have a
fairly seasoned audience today we have
the
almost half of you with more than five
years of experience and you know you'll
see some interesting information about
that but this is a great program for you
um as well as people who are at the
other end of the
experience Spectrum so
let me
move on
and we'll talk about how this program
prepares you
so
I'll cover the
the way we built the curriculum and
build your your skills in in stepwise
fashion so that each module prepares you
for the next one in sequence
um you start off with an orientation
session
that just gives you uh
overview of what the curriculum is what
to expect in terms of your class
schedule
amount of projects and homework between
classes
how to work the learning management
system manage your curriculum keep track
of your progress all of those Basics
like a freshman orientation
and once you've completed that you move
on to the first formal module which is
Introduction to artificial intelligence
that's an overview of the field and the
basics principles and what you need to
know about how artificial intelligence
and machine Learning Works
um then you'll move on to uh module on
Python Programming so if you don't have
a programming background this is where
you'll obtain
skills that you need in this
program to do
the python work
so don't have to worry about coming in
with python knowledge you'll get that
during the the course of the program
after that basic module you'll start
looking at how python is used in data
science which is the fundamental
underpinning of Ai and ml
and once you have that experience that
practice you'll be able to go into the
machine learning module and understand
how machine Learning Works how data
modeling Works how
algorithms can improve themselves by
taking in new data and adjusting
based on what the data tells them
which is the basic of machine learning
and then you'll move past that into deep
learning tools like Keras and tensorflow
um and then into some Advanced topics
um and once you're past that you do your
Capstone project which is something I'll
describe in just a minute that's
essentially a final project that ties
together all of the skills that you've
learned in the previous modules
unless you solve a
industry-based real world type problem
and then your solution becomes part of
your permanent portfolio and it's
practical experience along with the
other projects you've done that you can
show off to potential future employers
along the way you can take any or all of
the electives these are at no additional
cost uh they're included in the program
uh so they're based on whether you have
the time and inclination for them you
can look
even the statistics Essentials if you
need more uh
remedial background on that you can go
deeper into natural language processing
speech recognition you can look at
reinforcement learning and then along
the way as I think
um
Mike had said there's
master classes from Caltech ctme
instructors who will share with you
the research they've been doing how and
ml is applied in their work
those are really fascinating classes as
well so
all of that
in the curriculum
and then you have the ability to uh
use all of these tools so it's not a
matter of you'll be exposed to them it's
a matter of you'll be required to use
them all so Python and numpy's as a
Mike mentioned
you'll be using regularly you'll be
using tools like Keras and tensorflow
and you get into the
Advanced machine learning you'll be
using Django flash flask rather opencv
and uh
you learn to all of these types of tools
you need to use in your projects in each
of the courses
and along the way then you'll be able to
add them to your resume with not just a
buzzword but you'll be able to say
here's work that I actually did with
each of these tools and platforms
and here are examples so you'll be able
to prove your skills uh in each of these
areas so
that's a valuable aspect of the program
and again as I mentioned the Capstone
project ties all of it together so
you'll get a challenge and we'll see a
few of those in a few minutes
that you'll get to pick one Challenge
and work on it for about three to four
weeks meet weekly with your instructor
to make sure that you're staying on
target with the uh progress on your
Capstone project and it will be
something that you build from scratch
yourself it becomes part of your git
portfolio that you can then
demonstrate your experience to other
people so it's really a valuable
practical experience tool or building
your future career
I'm going to share with you this
gentleman's story because it's
interesting for a couple of reasons he
took the the program at age 66.
so if any of you happen to be
more seasoned like myself and are
wondering whether there's some type of
age limit there isn't and we'll tell you
about the program
excuse me
artificial intelligence has already
become a part of our lives
and I wanted to learn more about it
the course is helping me tremendously in
my upskilling journey
hi I'm Daniel dick I'm 66 years old and
I'm semi-retired and live in California
with my wife and son
since childhood I've had a strong
interest in science and technology I was
fascinated by the way systems worked
internally and how algorithms performed
that after 40 years of working in
technology sector I could no longer work
it hit me hard
I looked at how well my daughter was
doing as a software engineer my daughter
became my inspiration up skill and over
the years I pursued various courses in
different fields of computer science
I realized that technology has the power
to change the world
I worked rigorously in the health care
sector as a technocrat
and I know technology can revolutionize
it
I wanted to know how it could be used in
the health care sector or other sectors
so I could contribute to those domains
whenever I start something of my own
so I chose the AIML boot camp from
Simply learn in association with Caltech
ctme
the course is practical all of my new
details and concepts are explained in
the most simplistic manner
the curriculum was well designed
considering Learners from different
backgrounds it was an amalgamation of
practical labs and Theory
program focuses on building a
problem-solving attitude in Learners the
course is helping me tremendously in my
upskilling journey and solving real life
problems whatever the problem is you can
either solve it or learn to solve it by
upscaling yourself
[Music]
okay and so you saw in that uh some
glimpses of the learning environment
which allows you to manage your
curriculum you see all the component
courses that make up the program and it
keeps track of which one you're on and
which ones you've completed uh you've
got the live virtual classroom where you
take live lectures and interact directly
with your instructor and your fellow
classmates uh answer their questions
you've they answer yours uh you take
your tests and assessments and do your
labs and projects all online in the same
environment you saw how coding exercises
are done in the same sandbox environment
in the learning management system on a
virtual machine that's assigned to you
so you can do it from any place that you
have a web browser
we talked about the Capstone project and
we
mentioned that as you
pinch it finish each of your courses you
unlock a certificate for that course and
then ultimately when you're done all the
courses and completed the Capstone you
unlock that final certificate from
Caltech so support tools
have a community bulletin board
social media type experience where you
can ask questions from your instructors
and your peers and you also have the
ability to um
contact us on our 24x7 help desk so if
you have a problem with the platform
we're available to you but also if you
have subject matter questions we have
experts on call for that as well so
you're if you're working on a project at
three o'clock in the morning and you've
reached a
from dead end will be able to help you
with that
so
the program is under the direction of
Rick Hefner who is actually the
executive director of Caltech ctme
uh he is Mike's boss and he uh
oversees all of the programs from Celtic
ctme
specifically looks at uh the content of
the curriculum how it's delivered
who the people are that will deliver
master classes from the Caltech side
and
they make sure that this program meets
the rigorous standards of the
institution
so uh you already saw one of the learner
outcomes
from Mr dick but
you'll be learning alongside people from
a lot of different uh
backgrounds and organizations so people
who come into this program can come from
a whole wide range of different
organizations
not just technology not just software
but
also manufacturing e-commerce
um
uh financial banking
Pharma Health Care
gas oil exploration
just people who need to use machine
learning and that covers pretty much
every organization in the world today
so your class cohort may have people
from
a whole wide range of different
companies and you'll be able to
essentially uh learn alongside and from
them as well
uh here are some of the other Learners
who have taken this program Chris Felipe
and schlinder who all looked at
different aspects of the program a
Python Programming the uh data modeling
and deep learning and
had a particular favorite part
and as part of the program we will also
offer you a career assist service which
is which is something that will help you
find your next job if you are in the
market for that
um this is something where we work with
a company called Talent Inc and we offer
several different pieces of this
uh they extend for six months after you
earn your certificate from the program
so once you finish your Capstone unlock
your certificate you still get to access
these for another six months part of it
is the expert webinars that we run at
simply learn on an ongoing basis
with career advice and information about
technology Fields then we have the
projects that you do within the program
which become your portfolio of practical
experience demonstrate and then there's
the formal services from Talent Inc and
those include their resume rabbit portal
which gives you access to their
exclusive uh
job listings as well as a way to search
and apply for those jobs discreetly and
privately
the other two parts I think are
even more important one is resume review
and rewrite the top resume service
and the reason that's important is
because today resumes don't go to people
until they have gone through an
automated system automated tracking
system and an AI bot that evaluates the
content of your resume against the job
description
so your resume has to be written in a
way that the AI bot can recognize what's
in it
and make that
Association
easily and will tend to filter you in
rather than filter you out
um but then after that process if you
get filtered in it will go to a person
and it'll show up on their desktop or
their screen and it still has to look
attractive
to the human eye so uh having a resume
that fulfills both of those requirements
for the AI screening and for the human
appeal that's really a an art form and
that's what this part of the service
helps you with then the same thing about
the one-on-one interview service because
if you know from applying for work you
have
multiple rounds of interviews that start
with maybe a phone screen from a
recruiter or HR rep and then moves on to
technical interviews
from your media supervisor and your team
members who you'll be working with the
they'll want to evaluate your technical
skills and your knowledge of the field
and then you'll move on to cultural fit
and
are you a good team player and how do
you mesh with the the people at the
organization
each of those types of interviews
requires a slightly different approach
and the one-on-one interview service
will give you a chance to practice each
one of those live with the coach so
this is a really valuable service again
not a job guarantee or placement service
but it's a set of tools that you can use
in your job search and
you can use them as much or as little as
you want
I mentioned the expert webinars we do
have weekly webinars on different data
or technology fields overviews of the
industry what are the current trends we
sometimes do uh many courses learn at
live sessions where you go into a
particular technical skill and get a
one-hour lesson we also have a career
oriented webinars to teach you about how
to conduct a job search or how to
structure your career and develop the
soft skills you need to move ahead so
all of these are free all of these are
available to you lifelong
and then when we talk about the Capstone
project here's some examples of the
types of
challenges that you can choose from from
social media or from
Commerce manufacturing edtech Healthcare
so you'll you'll be able to pick a
problem
that interests you
and then solve that challenge with your
particular solution again it's a three
to four week processes and your solution
becomes your own part of your portfolio
to show off your new set of skills with
your practical experience
so as I mentioned before the program
fees are 9999 US dollars
um but I've talked about the bonus offer
the bonus offer for attending today's
webinar
is a 500 discount from those fees
down to 94.99
um if you enroll
from this webinar and you do that by
contacting ask us at
simplylearn.net I'm going to put that if
you will bear with me for a moment I
will put that into
the
chat
moment to copy that in
so you this is how you uh apply for the
program
contacting us at this email address
in the chat now
uh and Mike had mentioned that if you
have an employer with a tuition
reimbursement policy if this is
something that you're going to do that
will
um improve your job skills for your
current employer you can ask them about
the whether they have tuition
reimbursement to help you with some or
all of the costs of the program so
that's of course up to your individual
employers policies
but based on everything that Mike and I
have told you today
are you interested
level of Interest
so I'm going to leave this whole
question open for about 20 seconds again
it's a
yes or no so it's pretty straightforward
to close it in about
five seconds from now
four
three
two
[Music]
one
here's the result almost three quarters
of our audience are interested in
enrolling in
a program so that's great and I'm going
to share with you now the steps
or accomplishing that
on the enrollment steps very
straightforward again start by emailing
us at ask us at simplylearn.net
we will review I will ask you for some
additional information and review your
your application
again you only need to have a proof of
age and a proof of high school diploma
or GED
as a background for educational
background there will be however uh
request for
verifying your work history just to see
what how what work history you do have
does not have to be in the technology
field can be in any area and uh we'll
also give you a quick
assessment test of your knowledge of
math and
programming skills just to see where you
are and make sure that you have the
aptitude to
handle the work then we'll also ask you
questions about your interest in the
field and your level of commitment as
Mike said you're going to be putting in
a
six-month commitment where you need to
plan on showing up every weekend for our
Saturday for our Sunday for the live
classes and then putting in some work in
between to do the projects and
preparation work so
you don't have to be there every single
weekend because we know that people you
have other things that happen in their
lives and you can catch up on a take
care of class you miss by watching a
recording but you do have to meet a
certain
percentage of the live classes in order
to qualify for completing each course so
I need to plan as if you'll need to be
there every weekend
once you receive your admission letter
uh
started and the schedule for that uh
actually starts next in April where on
the 12th you can
um
pick the first welcome class orientation
session and the actual live classes
start on May 6th so
again we we urge you to hurry so that
you can take advantage of that 500
discount offer
reach out to us and ask us at
simplylearn.net to do that
um just one follow-up question to the
last one which is for those of you who
are interested
uh how soon do you see yourself
enrolling something you want to do for
the
class sessions that start in may or is
it something you want to do maybe June
or a little later
and we'll leave this open for another
10 seconds
I'll close it five four three two one
there we go
share the result here
it's a 60 of our audience would like to
start either in that April May uh cohort
or uh maybe the one after that
and for those of you who are looking
further out do contact us at ask us
simplylearn.net and what we'll do is
we'll keep in touch with you keep you
advised of future cohorts and we'll also
be able to answer any questions that you
have
um in interim
so
um this is where we start with questions
and answers and I see there are a number
of them in the Q a
so let me
not making you look at that slide
I will pull up
q a questions and I'll address those let
me also check real quick to see if we
received I haven't seen any transcribed
from our
live stream
uh
graph
this is just a recording but can I still
ask questions well part of it was a
recording Mike was recorded but I am
here live so I can answer your questions
will we get proof of attendance for this
webinar at this particular session uh
the next question I'll be asking in a
poll you can request that
um
is the 15 hours per week of virtual
class time
so we have eight hours of live virtual
classes in the courses that include live
classes some of them are done by uh
self-study but ones that include live
classes include four hours on Saturday
four hours on Sunday generally from
eight to noon on the morning
so that uh Pacific time so that if
you're on the west coast where Caltech
is located
do it in the mornings on the weekend if
you happen to be taking the course from
uh let's say the East Coast it would be
the afternoon
um
and then the rest of the time commitment
is
projects and labs and
assessments and other prep work where
you're watching for example pre-recorded
video material to get oriented for what
the class is going to be about that week
all of that adds into the rest of the
time
um what if there is someone interested
in the program and can't afford the fee
I would suggest you contact us at ask us
at simplylearn.net
um
and find out if there are any
programs that we might offer for that
but generally speaking we don't offer
too many scholarships or bursaries
generally the main assistance we're
giving you is the
500 bonus offer for today but again if
you are working and your employer will
cover some of this through tuition
reimbursement that's another Avenue to
pursue so look at that
uh what are the recommended
prerequisites
uh prerequisites again fall into
um just understanding basic math uh and
statistics principles so there's some
um a higher level of high school math
and early college math and then having
some understanding of how programming is
done so if you've done any
coding for yourself or if you've taken
any kinds of programming classes
high school for example generally those
are the types of things that that are
give you the background you you'll need
learning python is part of this program
so you don't have to come into the
program
pardon me with python knowledge
we'll help you with that so
how much one-on-one time can ex students
Suspect with Tas or instructors you can
schedule one-on-one time with
instructors through uh
office hours and uh
Project Help sessions so the
four hour sessions on the weekends are
class sessions their their group class
sections but you can uh request
one-on-one time
so I wouldn't expect more than maybe an
hour a week but uh
uh if not but it is possible to do
what type of programming would be the
best foundation for learning
specifically
uh you just need to understand
object-oriented program is always
principles of object-oriented
programming are important but um
basically if you understand how
computer programs are structured in
nature of algorithms
uh that's just the basis that you'll
need you don't need to have uh
deep understanding of programming tools
or techniques
uh
see
what if any career support is included
I've described that uh with our
job assist program
will the course require accessing a
cloud program like Google Cloud platform
the course will include all the tools
you need you'll be working through the
learning management system which is
cloud-based
um you will have a virtual machine
assigned to you where you can do your
work
um you aren't going to get too much into
Cloud questions about how to coordinate
um
program operation across the cloud or
containerization or any of that type of
thing but all the tools that are
available uh that are necessary for the
program will be available to you through
the learning management system
will participants be working in teams
generally not
um that that would be up to the
instructor for a particular course
what certificate will you get after this
course after the
boot camp if you enroll in the boot camp
you get the boot camp certificate
for today if you want to uh get a
certificate for being here that's just a
proof of attendance uh it won't be
much use in getting your job but the one
from Caltech
is the one from Caltech certifies that
Caltech
is able to say that you completed
program to their specifications
successfully and demonstrated all of the
new skills that you've learned
and that carries a lot of weight with
employers
um are there discounts available for
people over 66 years old I do not know
the answer to that but I would contact
ask us at simplylearn.net find out
and with that I've completed all of the
open questions so uh let me do a quick
check
of what's in the chat to see if there's
any other questions there
sorry
chat this is the chat
so can undergrads join this course
yes undergrads can join the course if
you have the commitment of time to do
the work so if you if you're
if you feel confident you can do this
course in addition with your your full
class load for your undergrad
and yeah you you uh you can join the
course of I don't know if we have
discounts again you would contact ask us
at simplylearn.net to ask that question
see if there's student discounts
when did this program start
this program has been going on for
several years with Caltech and simply
learn and the class cohorts start about
monthly
um
and again it's a six-month program so
one if you're starting with the May
classes you'd expect to continue through
to about November
um how can one find his first job in the
data science machine learning field
um most
most listings seem to require prior
experience
so there are uh definitely
if you look on LinkedIn Glassdoor dice
they're uh entry level
jobs available in the field
and having the ability to demonstrate
your skills with the Practical
experience you gain in this program in
the portfolio you'll carry out of it is
a definite help
um the job assist program will help you
with coaching on how to find that first
job
so again we're giving you uh much help
as we can in that process of finding
that first job so
uh
okay
I'm going to answer this for Jeff
although I know Jeff had to drop off
but he had a great question looking at
programs for over a year now ready to
move forward hardest part is choosing a
program and being confident in my choice
will I learn or will I just be watching
videos as I'm taking a class for you
well
you're not just watching videos for this
program you do have expert instructors
people who work in Industry uh who will
be sharing their expertise and
experience and not just academic
instructors but they share practical
examples
um and you'll be taking the classes live
in many of the courses
um live resources you have available
include the bulletin board but you can
also
contact your instructors and Tas for
live
interaction and you can also contact our
help desk to get Live help so all of
that is available to you and again I
this question says am I completely siled
no you're not because you have the
ability to compare your experience with
other students in your cohort
ask them for for help or advice or
compare notes or compare what was your
approach on this project
so all of that is available to you
you're not in an isolated environment
um
and why is this program worth more than
the uh IBM AI program the reason it's
worth more is it's far more extensive
and
comprehensive so
um and you get exposure to and
certificate from Caltech which in itself
has great value so with that I'm going
to conclude our
q a period
move on to our last question for you
and
our last question for you is
do you need assistance would you like us
to reach out to you
um
to help you enroll
see if I can find
button for that hold on a second
sorry
confuse myself for a second
here you go would you like us to reach
out to you and contact you if you wanted
to get a proof of attendance for today's
webinar uh answer yes and we'll we'll
send that to you
and um other than that let us know if
you want us to reach out to you
and
answer any further questions get you
started in the program
and I'll leave this open for another
five seconds
three
two one
and it's about
50 50.
so for those of you who answered yes we
will contact you and I will also send
you the proof of attendance for today's
session
and
for anyone else who is looking to get
involved contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net I'm also going to put
you can use the QR code that will take
you to
the
home page for the program
I'm going to put that URL also into the
chat so you can
go to the home page directly
put that in there and I will again
reiterate the
email address there
and
so you can contact us or you can find
out more information at the uh
web page
and I want to thank everyone for being
here today whether you're on our
streaming services or uh here live with
us in Zoom
um and we hope that we can welcome you
into the Learning Community with Caltech
and simply learn so thanks again for
being here
that's the end of our webinar for today
thank you
recording stopped